if you've been following our coverage
cover 19 you've probably seen me talking
about charts like this this shows you
death tolls
in various different countries around
the world the steeper these lines are
it's a logarithmic chart so the steeper
these lines are the faster these death
tolls have been rising but to be honest
with you I've always been a bit
frustrated by this because there is a
bit of an undercount going on here these
aren't telling you the full story and I
want to just explain why looking at the
UK in particular these numbers just show
you the number of people who are dying
of covert 19 in hospital so the latest
data we have show it's seventeen
thousand three hundred thirty-seven
hospital deaths in the UK but that is an
undercount by definition that's not
including deaths in care homes in
private homes but we are now starting to
get a sense of that and this is what I
want to show you because those official
death tolls aren't necessarily what the
reality is we now know that if you're
going back over the course of the last
few weeks it was a very different
picture when you're looking at all
deaths from covert 19 so deaths with
covert 19 on the death certificate
that's the black line there compare it
to the white line there's a difference
there isn't there how much of a
difference where you get a sense if you
look back on the 10th of April we were
told by the government back then but in
hospitals 8950 eight people had died of
covert 19 now we know according to these
new statistics that actually the real
death toll around then was 11,000 413 so
these are deaths across the UK for all
quarters from from all settings so
including in care homes as well it
doesn't look like that much of a
difference does it but actually it
represents a 28% under count and if you
extrapolate that out over the course of
the following weeks because that's kind
of a bit in their past you're talking
now about us having a death toll that's
not around 17,000 it is around 22,000
deaths
maybe even more so there's official
numbers aren't telling you the full
story we now know that and we also know
that even that 22,000 might well be an
understatement as well why because let's
look at numbers that don't just rely on
whether something over 19 is on the
death certificate we'll look at all
causes of death and
line shows you the weekly average for
the weeks of the years so these this
axis shows you weeks of the year we're
now at week 15 the weekly average over
the past five years was that if we had a
real problem now you would expect all
cause mortality to shoot up very sharply
well let me add the line for 2020 and
while there we are you can see very
sharp increase indeed that is up to
eighteen thousand five hundred and
sixteen deaths in the fifteenth week of
the year that represents what's a
physician's call excess debts about
8,000 excess deaths so above the average
you would normally have in that week of
the year eight thousand but here's the
intriguing thing of that eight thousand
six thousand two hundred thirteen we
know had covered 19 on the death
certificate but that still doesn't
explain an extra one thousand seven
hundred and eighty three thousands of
people are dying in short right now and
we don't have an explanation we're not
able to attribute it to Cove at nineteen
it must be something else either cope of
19 deaths that haven't been registered
as that or something else entirely we
just simply don't know but we do know a
lot of people are dying right now
and the upshot of all of that is that we
have a situation now that's getting
closer to unprecedented territory are we
an unprecedented chirchi when you look
at look at overall deaths in the UK not
quite let me take this and get rid of
that line just looking about five years
and look back over the course of the
last half century so fifty years every
dot on this each of these blue dots
represents another week going back to
1970 and you can see how this line
compares eighteen a half thousand
actually it's not as high as we saw in
the first week of two thousand it's also
not quite as high as towards the end of
1989 a big flu pandemic then as well and
it's also not quite as high as we saw in
early 1970 that was the Hong Kong flu so
it's clear that this is not quite
unprecedented territory in terms of
deaths what is unusual is when those
deaths are happening they're happening
in the spring they're not happening in
the winter the start of the year or at
the end of the year
they're happening in the spring that's
very different very unusual and we
simply we haven't seen that before going
back 50 years at least of data and
there's the same story as well as I was
showing you
those unexplained deaths when you look
at care homes as well this shows you the
average of deaths going back to the
start of the Earth's first ten weeks of
the year and again it's a similar
picture when you look at deaths in care
homes and have a look you've got one and
a half thousand excess deaths in care
and how many of those who explained by
Cove at nineteen 826 which means there
is another 643 that just aren't
explained by Ovid 19 that's about 45% of
all excess deaths in care homes don't
have an explanation that comes down to
covet 19 now that means either we are
under counting kovat 19 deaths
considerably even these supposedly most
authoritative numbers might be under
Counting covet 19 deaths or something
else is going on the good news is we may
now be just about beyond the peak for
deaths in the UK the bad news is well
these statistics might well under count
the reality